[Musique]
salut tout le monde bonjour je suis très
content parce qu on a chopé cette boîte
là avec le heat c'est une trique boxe
savate ou in one littéralement deux en
un l'idée c'est d'avoir une petite
partie un peu casse tête triki mais
après c'est pas ça qui ouvre la boîte il
va falloir ensuite trouver comment
ouvrir la boîte donc c'est sympa quand
même temps ouais ouais ouais loïc
deux jeunes
il est agréable d'être captés sur ses
claviers virtuels logique hautement
technologique
mon dieu une alerte de style alerte
hante
que se passe-t-il soldats loïc saison
bizarre mais pose et l'adjudant loïc
mais enfin vous n'avez pas d'idée
commandant loïc ça me paraîtrait c'est
un peu caporal musique
nous allons jouer à 0 city cette vidéo
est soutenu par le jeu 0 city alors 0
city c'est quoi bon écoutez je veux dire
qu'est ce que c'est sita simulateur
gratuit où vous devez survivre en créant
l'escouade la plus puissante pas du tout
colonel lake
enfin si un petit peu quand même en
quelque sorte parce que c'est un peu
mais c'est pas tout à fait le propos
vous devez créer un abri pour lutter
contre les autres joueurs et les
créatures affectés mangeuse de sergio 1
ça c'est du plastique ce combat vous
pouvez améliorer vos persos avec des
nouveaux styles les améliorer mais aussi
les équiper et les habiller en créant du
nouveau matos et une possibilités du jeu
on doit créer des armes des équipements
hyper efficace et armer son équipe
pourquoi écoutez je suis foutu hier
troufions loïc il ya des centaines de
bataille avec des hordes de zombies et
de mutants fanatiques face à vos bras
combattants dont si vous ne faites rien
il ne restera plus qu était plus haut
niveau de cerveau c'est ça qu'on veut
loïc va nous plaire le truc que j'ai
plussé mais personnellement dans le jeu
c'est qu'on peut soit attaqué les autres
abris soit faire des tournois soit joué
une campagne il ya une vraie histoire et
un côté jeu de rôle 0 city c'est un bon
jeu gratuit post apocalyptique des
graphismes hd plutôt stylée et vous
pouvez télécharger le jeu vient mon bien
parce que ce genre de sponsor ça
soutient la chaîne vous le savez et
surtout en passant par mon lien vous
obtiendrez un bonus spécial de 3500
piette et 250 crypto pièces pour les
nouveaux joueurs vous fait voir un petit
peu la boîte comment aller je l'exploit
un peu avec vous même si ça ce sera dans
un deuxième temps parce qu'il est très
clairement annoncé quand tu l'achètes
que dans un premier temps il faut
libérer les deux billes qui a ici sur le
dessus
il faudrait quoi il faudrait que
j'arrive soit avoir une balade dans ce
cas les billons l'essor par là enfin
j'imagine
voilà ce qu'on les fera rentrer plus
tard bon j'en ai aucune idée donc je
vais arrêter d'avoir des hypothèses
abalo faut les faire sortir par ici
évidemment fabien vous faut les faire
sortir juste par l'as far par ce petit
truc là qu'on voit donc il faut trouver
un chemin pour faire passer les bulles
alors il va se passer un truc très relou
les aime mais vraiment relou cela va
être de les faire bouger comme ça les
morceaux donc là par contre moi je vais
clairement prendre un truc
tiens ça comme ça je vais bougerait plus
facilement corps au [ __ ] puisqu'il ya
assez chaud séjour quelqu'un ça va pas
fabien vient de prendre un couteau un
couteau mais pour quoi faire
je peur qu'il fasse une bêtise je pense
qu'il va tuer le casse tête non mais ça
c'est un ouvre lettre de quoi nous voilà
pour ouvrir et la plus facile en ouvre
lettre est ce que tu es naïf
pourquoi est ce que ray un couteau pour
rire des lettres importe quoi et
pourquoi pas une cuillère pour aider à
mettre ses chaussures
comment chose qui est par exemple un
chausse pied ah oui tu vois du coup tu
reprends la vidéo stable la vidéo du
jeune mec je reprends merci ok alors là
je vais étudier un peu on va étudier un
petit peu le chemin là vous voyez là le
chemin qui a là c'est lui qui va nous
intéresser
ce sera le chemin pour les billes mais
en fait on est on est clairement sur un
double chemin il ya le chemin noir
c'est ce qui va permettre de bouger ça
les pièces donc les pièces peuvent elles
peuvent pas aller partout n'importe
comment et le chemin blanc ça va être le
truc débile leiby emprisonnés c'est une
vie qu'on pourra pas sortir
du coup ça me bloque le chemin d'une
manière ou d'une autre
ok donc là du coulage d'une modique des
raiders biais d'accords ont baissé
partir on y va on est parti qu'est ce
que je cherche à faire
je cherche en fait ce qui serait bien
c'est que je charge cette bille dans
celui ci puisque celui ci après il peut
être en regard avec lui donc en fait
j'aimerais que j'aimerais que ça lui et
lui ils soient en phase là c'est pas du
tout cas là pour le moment mais là
regardez qu'est ce qui va se passer
ils vont être en face n'a de doute c'est
pas chiant du tout faire tomber sa non
remonte un peu remonte un peu entre tu
remontes à les contrats sur la bi et là
je refais le chemin que j'avais vu mais
dans l'autre sens ce qui va nous libérer
la première bille non mais pourquoi ils
dérangent plus à punaises à la foire est
bon sa difficulté cinq sur six es1
difficultés extrêmes et j'ai eu tort
mais en fait c'est assez tranquille pas
du tout regardé la notion des deux
chemins de vous disait le chemin noir et
le chemin de cette pièce de bois elle me
permet d'avancer les pièces de bois ya
pas de soucis mais le chemin blanc est
belle à la petite bille elle n'est pas
dans le chemin blanc ou croit cahier
bayer peau alors est-ce que si je passe
comme ça à l'envers est-ce que là ça
passerait à temps je me suis fait
vraiment clairement bêtement à voir là
la faune acceptent des sand à nohant la
ccss est possible descente après comme
ça comme ça comme ça la [ __ ] mais là
non plus on ne peut pas amenam hélas est
par contre possible mais ça c'est pas
possible
ok on est parti sur la nouvelle vidéo de
17 heures locales
est-ce que je peux pas non non on en
reste là bas tout va bien chez toi
est-ce que je peux pas juste
re libérer la bille essayé de lui faire
prendre de l'avancé par rapport à lui
wahou pas simple parce que cette vie si
elle avait été là j'aurais pu la charge
est donc en fait si lui et l as well as
je pourrais la charge et ça c'est sûr et
du coup la décharge et à ce moment là
pour la faire entrer dans l'ue donc
j'aimerais bien que lui soit inversée
avec lui comment je resserre pour ça
peut faire ça peut faire ça peut faire
ça le faire ça je peux faire ça mais je
peux faire ça descend toi par contre lui
j'ai besoin qu'il va se charger du coup
tu es dans le sens ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
de jean jacques fabi m'appelle jean
jacques fabi comme les familles en jean
jacques
ce sont les gens jacques fabi
sauf que quand tu chantes il ya un petit
truc qui se dégage j'aimerais bien que
ce soit toi en fait directement tristane
de punchlines non il aurait fallu que je
puisse lui remettre avant le temps lubie
loïc je réclame une accélération pour
pouvoir faire n'importe quoi et mettre
ma tête c'est possible
[Musique]
voilà on va libérer la première bille la
première bille libéré donc c'était bien
le la théorie que j'avais de essayer de
mettre dans cette situation là essayer
d'être dans cette situation là c'est à
dire cette force là ici avec beaucoup
d'avant un trou là et le jaune ici ça me
permettait de faire descendre la bi là
que le jeune vient de récupérer ensuite
et les jets que c'est exactement ce
qu'on a vu donc il faut réussir
maintenant reproduire ça avec l'autre
billes en repartir sur une petite
accélération se pensant à et du coup le
blanc va me servir à la charge est ok
c'est reparti s'accélère
[Musique]
ok on arrive à ce que je voulais c'est
blanc car il ici j'ai crevé loïc 1 on
n'a pas commencé vraiment l'ouverture de
la boîte je suis crevée clairement alors
lui on voulait le transférer en ai dit
comment albi puisse remplacer comme ça
oui comme ça comme ça là j'avais fait
trop de tout à l'heure c'est comme ça
que j'avais mis lui dans le mmy et
ensuite la balle là ça va c'est bon ok
ça va faire claque là le jaune vous
l'amener là leblanc faut le faire
remonter le rouge à droite le jaune on
le descend le blanc sur la droite le
rouge on monte la billon la libère on a
fait manger par le jaune le blanc
redescend yes le rouge
à droite le jaune remonte elle à
deuxième billet libéré ok puis mort mon
gars tu vous choper la boîte alors vous
pouvez l'acheter je vous mets le lien
dans la description sinon je vous la
fais gagner sur instagram sous ce poste
là comme à chaque fois que je fais guère
un casse tête après je le fais gagner
par contre si si si vous le faites
prenez à stylo un truc pour vous aider
parce que ta bouche bien c'est pas le
problème mais il suffit que la boule un
tout petit peu et des fois c'est pas où
est donc là maintenant on va passer sur
il faut ouvrir la boîte alors là je fais
la phase d'exploration c'est pour ça que
je touche un petit peu à tout mais ça je
sens que si je perds trop fort de 6 à
vannes l'abîmé ça c'est pareil ça c'est
pareil non je vais surtout pas remettre
de billes ici parce que je ne suis pas
idiot et j'ai vraiment pas l'impression
qu'on puisse bouger quelque chose par
contre je me dis bouger les deux bis a
clairement servi à rien face à la maison
ne savait pas grand chose le mais par
contre ici on a un trou ici au mans un
trou avec une planche donc y'a rien qui
peut y passer mais il est de la taille
de la bille peut-être je peux appuyer
d'ailleurs on voir ce qui se passe rien
l'habille elle tomberait dedans ça c'est
sûr
ici avais tu vois s'est passé un truc là
ou pas ici j'ai l'impression que s'est
appuyé sur quelque chose ici rien et ici
aussi je peux mettre une vie donc je
pense qu'on devait libérer les deux
billes pour pouvoir appuyer peut-être
sur des choses dont j'ai essayé ça comme
ça en mettant les deux noms se fait rien
de spécial bon si je la mets là dedans
n'a rien fait de spécial dans ce sens là
rien de spécial ici parce que là
celui-ci a mais attend une de chaque
côté alors ça me paraît pas être un
hasard qu'elle puisse rentrer comme ça
de chaque côté les deux bijoux
alors je pense qu'elle va s'ouvrir comme
ça à la fin la boîte [ __ ] ça fait rien
de spécial c'est bizarre ça a l'air trop
penser pour ne pas être ça tu vois c'est
bloqué mabille je connaissais le bloquer
alors justement c'est exactement ça
qu'il fallait faire attention soit j'ai
bloqué une bille soit c'est un début de
solution pourtant je n'ai pas enfoncé
comme un barbare non plus voilà
enclencher quelque chose tu sais ça
arrive ça tài tu mets une bille vas tu
as pu quelque part ça enclenche et du
coup tu as l'impression que c'est coincé
mais d'un autre côté si tu appuies
s'inverse et s'annule est-ce que je peux
la cape taper sur la vie de ce côté ah
oui c'est la débloquer moi j'écris une
énigme un casse-tête dans la dans le
casse tête
j'ai réussi à débloquer la vie c'est
forcément avec ces histoires de trous et
de billes n'ya pas dément là il ya des
trucs qui peuvent accueillir une petite
planche est un peu comme celle ci ce
qu'il faudrait pas réussir à débloquer
ces planchettes pour les mettre là
dedans et appuyez sur quelque chose
tout se passe avec les billes un poids
de
massip a bien dit que tout se passe avec
les billes hop je signe un décret les
billes c'est l'avenir c'est nier le
président des états unis du monde
oui jean michael je suis actuellement
devant la plus grosse fabrique que des
billes du comté et je ne parle pas du
fromage ou la production bat son plein
depuis les palais mais oui chérie je
t'avais dit que c'était l'avenir les
billes c'est les autres qui ont les
boules maintenant comme ils fabriquent
tous des casse tête avec des idées
différentes est ou qui diamé cf trop il
faut que j'ai pris un peu là ou que je
tape un peu là on est d'accord que si je
la mets dedans
elle veut pas aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est après le elle peut tomber dedans
et alors est ce qu'elle est vraiment
dans la zone la plus basse
ou est ce que parce qu'elle me trouve
vraiment au départ on peut le faire au
sensitif bénin ainsi je prouve que
j'avais mis le doigt sur quelque chose
pour que je la fasse tomber le ciel
allait tomber
pas du tout ok donc se troue la cnar ya
cinq points
là par contre c'est ici qu'elle s'était
bloquée a l'impression que j'appuie sur
quelque chose
ce cas là quand même vachement bien
enfoncer c'est quand même bizarre
oh oh oh
[Musique]
non ok on va comprendre
après donc la boîte aller ouverte et
elle se elle s'ouvre comme ça mais le
souverain en entier moi c'est ça le
s'ouvre pas en entier 1 par contre il
faut pas il faut pas s'amuser à l'ouvrir
plus insondable mois elle là il n'y a
pas de jeu est tous d'accord ça c'est la
vraie ouverture on a là j'ai trouvé la
vraie ouverture loïc je suis pas sûr ah
si si c'était bon l'habit coincé c'était
ça la technique
[ __ ] j'avais bon depuis le départ mais
en fait comme si dubois et s'était du
travail t'as pas envie d'appuyer trop
fort de forcer ok là il ya les deux
jambes et cette jambe la halle à un
petit truc qui ressort là dedans et en
fait il fallait donc enfoncé labit
dessus pour que ça commence à appuyer et
appuyer vraiment fermement avec l'autre
billes et sa libérer la passe est juste
ça ça suffisait après avec le v donc ça
s'ouvrait pas comme ça comme je le
pensais d'ailleurs
[ __ ] elle était trop cool cette boîte
mais c'est surtout je trouve quand même
le concept trésorerie et après claque
obs trop bien tourner le concept très
original en plus d'avoir le labyrinthe
c'est à dire que les deux petits outils
qui vont me servir après appuyé sur la
petite de gambettes là bas il faut déjà
quand même résoudre ce truc au dessus
qu'est pas si simple et parce qu'en fait
des fois tu as des bottes secrètes les
gens qui savent comment après sa sous la
botte secrète tu vois et en fait ils
peuvent le tu peux pas cacher un truc
vraiment personne dedans parce qu'ils
peuvent l'ouvrir trop vite s'ils
connaissent la même si tu connais faut
quand même se taper le petit truc de
départ et a vraiment avoir envie de
récupérer les billes pour l'ouvrir je
trouve ça trop cool c'est un super casse
tête 5 sur 6 largement méritée mais en
même temps tout à fait faisable bien
dans la description pour l'obtenir est à
gagner sur instagram comme d'habitude
dans la photo en fait de ce parce qu'il
faudra commenté je reviens pour
remercier 0 city de voir fondre ceaurriz
et cette vidéo voilà moi j'aime bien le
jeu dans des aménagements mais c'est
plutôt cool d'avoir toutes ces
possibilités aussi de jeu vous pouvez
soutenir la chaîne évidemment en testant
ce jeu gratuit vous avez un lien dans la
description et en plus vous obtiendrez
le boudu spéciale de 3500 kg est 250
crypto pièce réservée aux nouveaux
joueurs
vous pouvez continuer en regardant cette
vidéo c'est un abonné qui m'a fabriqué
ce casse-tête l'a sûrement un des
meilleurs casse tête de la chaîne ou
alors cette petite boîte là que si elles
étaient achetés c'est l' einstein box y
avait quelque chose de surprenant dans
cette boîte regardez ces vidéos là et
moi je vous dis à très bientôt
charroux